[Musique]
imaginez un jardin où les plantes brille
dans la nuit comme des veilleuses leurs
secrets on a modifié leur génome pour y
intégrer des gènes d'un champignon du
minet sans une équipe de chercheurs
internationaux de l'entreprise planta
ont récemment publié leurs exploits dans
nature biotechnology
[Musique]
ils ont tiré profit de la découverte
récente du processus par lequel certains
champignons émettent de la lumière
ils ont misé sur une molécule au coeur
de ce processus est également présente
chez des plantes
la sicafi les plantes ici des plants de
tabac ont été modifiées génétiquement en
y insérant des jeunes du champignon en
poussant elles se sont mises à briller
de façon autonome
cette lumière peut ainsi être utilisé
pour observer le fonctionnement interne
des plantes par exemple
à
dans le passé d'autres chercheurs ont
aussi tenté de rendre des plantes
luminescentes grâce au génie génétique
en utilisant des gènes présents chili
lucioles ouchy des bactéries
bioluminescente il ya deux ans une
équipe des mighty à most ont opté pour
une autre approche
la nano biotique c'est-à-dire diffusé à
l'aide de nanoparticules des enzymes
d'un organisme luminescents dans tous
les tissus et des cellules de la plante
les résultats étaient convaincants mais
l'effet de courte durée à peine plus de
trois heures l'utilisation nouvelles des
gènes de champignons pour modifier le
plan de tabac permet d'induire une
luminescence qui durent plus longtemps
tout le cycle de vie de la plante
c'est durant la croissance qu'elles
émettent davantage de lumière en
particulier dès l'apparition des fleurs
la lumière décroît ensuite avec le
vieillissement des feuilles des
chercheurs estiment que la lumière émise
correspond à un milliard de photons à la
minute
juste assez pour l'apercevoir à l'oeil
nu la manipulation génétique ne semble
pas affecter le taux de germination du
plant d'abba pas plus que son niveau de
floraison mais de telles plaintes ne
feront pas le saut demain dans vos
jardins
encore faudra-t-il étudier leur
comportement dans différents
environnements et mesurer le risque
qu'elle pourrait éventuellement poser
pour des contaminations croisées
une fois au milieu naturel
[Musique]